ولدينا ايضا شهاده من المسعف معين ابو
العيش من سكان معسكر جباليه في غزه اجبر
على البقاء في جنوب القطاع بعيدا عن اسرته
بعد ان قام الاحتلال بمنع سياره الاسعاف
التي كان يقودها من العوده شمالا بعد مهمه
نقل نقل خلالها جرحه من شمال القطاع الى
معبر
رفع
من بدايه الحرب عدد المصابين اللي كنا
نشيلهم اقل من العدد اللي اليوم اليوم عدد
المصابين عدد مهول عدد كبير عائلات
كامله كانت يعني جزء منها كبير تحت
الانقاض بقدر نطلعه نبذل جهد كبير مع
الدفاع
المدني والزملاء
في الكوارث عشان ننا نطلع المصابين اذا
كان في اح احياء من تحت
الانقاض بنقدم المصابين لهم خدمات اثناء
نقلهم من الميدان
وبنسلم في الخدمات خدمات الطوارئ في
الاسعاف وبيتم التعامل معهم والحالات اللي
كانت
صعبه
وحرجه ب بنقوم بنقلها بشكل اي مره ثانيه
الى اللي هو المستشفيات لاستكمال العلاج
تخافيش تخافيش تخافيش تخافيش تخافيش
يابا لا اخفى عليك انه في هناك خوف خوف
شديد جدا خوف شديد جدا لسببين يعني انه
احنا المناطق اللي احنا بنروح عليها يعني
هي مستهدفه بتكون وما زال الاستهداف عليها
يعني مازال قذائف تنزل على البيوت واحنا
رايحين العدو تبعنا ما عند انسانيه بالمص
للاسف الشديد
هو بيفهم شي اسمه انسانيه فبالتالي يستهدف
الكل اذا كان طبيب اذا كان مريض اذا كان
طفل اذا كان شيخ اذا كان ست حامل ايا كان
في طريقه حتى الله يكرمك الدواب قصفهم في
الشوارع بالعاده وبطبيعه وبظروف الطبيعيه
احنا بننقل ما بننقل اكثر مصاب عشان نقدر
نتعامل معها وكن للاسف الشديد في الحالات
هاي احنا بنحاول نشيل قدر المستطاع قدر
المستطاع نخلي من المكان الناس بتكون
معفره الناس بتكون محروقه اطفال انت بتشيل
من تحت الانقاض مواليد يعني حتى المواليد
اللي له مولود شهر او شهر ونص بتلاقيه
يعني مصاب وتحت الانقاض بنطلع وبناخذ
معانا قدر المستطاع بنقدر ناخذ في الاسعاف
بنحط الحالات الصعبه على الستشر او بنيمهم
والباقي احنا نحطهم في ارضيه السياره او
ممكن حتى زمايلنا المسعفين يعني حضنوا بعض
الاطفال او
الرضع في الكبينه الاماميه وتم نقلهم الى
المستشفى الشاره الدوليه اللي احنا
بنحملها في سيارات الاسعاف لم تكن كافيه
ولا حامي ولا رادع لهذه الغطرسه
الاسرائيليه الذي يتمتع
بها الجيش
الاسرائيلي
تم الطلب منا والاستغاثه منا من خلال
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه
ل ارسال سياره اسعاف من جمعيه
العوده الى مستشفى الاندونيسي لحمل مصابين
الى معبر رفح لاصاله الى جمهوريه مصر
العربيه وطبعا احنا وصلنا المصابين اللي
معنا ورجعنا عان نروح كانت الطريق مغلق
وتم اطلاق النار علينا مش قادر اروح لانه
قفلوا الطريق فصلوا بين
اي الجنوب والشمال عيلتي الان في الشمال
قطعوا النت عنا وقطعوا التواصل حتى مع
الاهل برا اللي بدهم يطمنوا علينا
و بيكلموني يعني من حين لحان لما تصير
اتصالات بيكلموني يعني بطمن علي وبطمن
عليهم
وينها
اطلع